en mai je dis ce qu'il me plaît ce
mois-ci guillancour donne la parole aux
jeunes pour connaître leurs besoins et
les associer aux décisions de la mairie
ce mardi soir une trentaine de jeunes
âgés de 11 à 25 ans ont répondu à
l'appel ils sont venus assister à la
première consultation public ce soir on
a des jeunes qui sont venus
volontairement s'exprimer dire ce qu'ils
ont envie des frustrations des fois des
idées des projets ce soir on va prendre
toutes ces idées là débattre avec eux
permettre aussi de distinguer ce qui
relève de la mairie et ce qui ne relève
pas de la mairie et leur dire que en
tout cas toutes ces idées vont être
réfléchies vont être pensées ensuite par
les élus de la ville pour que il y ait
en faveur des jeunes en tout cas une
politique la plus adéquate pour mieux
cibler leurs envies la ville a créé deux
questionnaires selon l'âge des
participants ils peuvent le remplir en
ligne sur le site de la ville un moyen
simple de connaître les lieux qu'ils
veulent fréquenter à Guille en cour à
chaque fin de partie notamment culture
et sport on demande aux jeunes et on
espère qui qui vont répondre au
questionnaires on leur demande de donner
le av ce qu'il voudrait voir de neuf si
par exemple des fois peut-être qu' a
rien à voir de neuf parfait c'est le
meilleur des mondes ou soit des fois
évidemment on espère qu'il y aura des
demande après il faudra quantifier voir
ce que ce que les élus veulent faire ou
non le maire annoncera de nouveaux
engagements en octobre prochain d'ici là
trois autres consultations de jeunes
auront lieu dans les maisons de quartier
de la ville